l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono pari j
oggi siamo su un qualcosa di strano
parto con un presupposto enorme questo
non è un videogioco ok ragazzi non
quello che state per vedere non era un
videogame
non so se vi ricordate tipo escaping
prison tutti quei giochi che ho fatto
con gli stick men gli stessi creatori di
questi stickman hanno fatto una specie
di cosa che non gli spoiler o per niente
perché la vedremo adesso insieme non è
un videogame e un diciamo video questa
più che altro una reaction si è pronti
ragazzi o parto tanto questa è la
tavoletta grafica è una figata
vorrei usarla tanto anche io problema è
che non so disegnare neanche un papavero
fatto su facebook anch'io quando i tuoi
video sono su facebook fisso e ragazze
lo dico ok già scritto devo andare
fantastico
niente comunque sono è un figo c'è stato
bellissimo
cioè è bellissima questa cosa non so
perché arrivando in trip bellissimo
a questo deve andare in lavanderia
perfetto si lascia il tuo computer
acceso tanto si muovono solo i cosi a
caso vai tranquillo ragazzi emessa cosa
mandato in tripla in un tipo assurda è
svenuto alla vivo perfetto è bellissimo
no vabbè ecco io qua non ci sono già
arrivato ero arrivato molto prima cioè
frigo e quindi cioè dovrebbero farci un
gioco su sta roba che facessero altri
minchia semerano pure fantastico è
questo qua credo che sia un gioco che
esista davvero ti posti fight ma roba
del genere perché è la madonna arrivato
quello rosso che fa il culo a tutti
coloro trova sempre il culo a tutti i
ragazzi questo è per adesso
sì è un figo amico mio vorresti essere
come lui vedo di la verità eccolo eccolo
il partito ha deciso di seguire le sue
orme ragazzi problema è che sta cercando
di entrare giusto in ama notato io beh
io vedo sempre detto ragazzi usate la
testa funziona in qualsiasi è promo ti
menano ma cerca pranzi diretto proprio
lei a testa più grossa degli altri
questa cosa ahi ahi liberati proprio
amica si menavano come se non ci fosse
un domani figurati potevamo uscire l'oro
che vogliono uscire è un'orgia perché
catasta più grosso lo vide succede è
insomma è carina questa cosa erano tutti
su facebook ovviamente ragazzi se non si
va su facebook tutti a scassare le parla
posizioni cosa fanno oh mio dio
ragazzi questo qua quando torna a casa
col computer sono cazzi suoi vero di
olbia 0 e poi impazzito nuovo bastardo
vuole chiudere processo no ragazzi non
potete el ausilio come li sta uccidendo
tutti pian piano mio dio è uno
stillicidio
ma perché mi chiedo se tornassi in
camera mi avete si sta roba
ci terrei ancora le ha ucciso tutti i
camici ma no sii serio
ok è un maledetto però e non si fanno se
cosa è la molla neanche presa troppo
bene mi dicono esagerati sia mi sembra
troppo crudele is not responding non può
chiuderlo l'arancione vita anzi
incazzato come dio
i miei amici adesso ti finisco io ma
come oh mio dio dov'è questa è una
tragedia ragazzi cosa fa voglio porre
fine alla mia vita non ce la faccio più
ma come egli ha messo pure like che
insensibile potresti cancellati dagli
amici solo per questo ora che faccia con
incazzata e qui lewis in casa del brutto
mica ninja non ero io
certo vallo a spiegare che banda di
perdenti dov è bravissimo vincenti
vai fuori il partito uno muore a caldo
di vini vvv orribili ma effettivamente
fan boschivo giudizio chi vuole che gli
stalker i nel sonno
lo farò io lo voglio le fotografie
cos'hanno affermi famiglie le tue
capacità fotografiche solo come le care
cannucce significa che fanno schifo
certo madonna se distruggendo facebook
cos'è l'ira di zuckerberg itunes sono i
due grazie a dio non c'ho l'iphone sta
facendo al disco metis veloce grazie
cèline erika a branzi ma potendo così il
filato nell'iphone nuova ben sei serio
quindi adesso ce l'hai nell'iphone
perfetto
il problema non è il fatto di averlo
nell'iphone 9 applausi per qualcosa che
appena un successo che il genio ha
inventato sta roba ma voglio
dategli le medaglie subito prendimi se
poi tu ma strada maestra era vabbè mica
hiroshima soggetto ma proprio guarda
caso
è una roba ecco fantastico gli ha tolto
tutto il problema è che dropbox a sud
troppo se non lo prendi più è amico mio
e tornato sul computer mi sa credo è non
ne sono sicurissimo del 6 con comi e sia
lui per forza va bene dice la violenza
sui cursori poteva evitarsi diciamo no
alla violenza sui cursore del mouse non
ha preso ha preso sempre ma no pensavo
avesse preso lo hanno detto è un cursore
distruttivo è impiccato il cursore del
mouse fantastico c'e ragazzi geniale
aggiunte in italy e dai e subito le
voglio subito tutte per lui non riesce a
ucciderlo ecco perché avanzi non può far
niente perfetto no della rai ha fatto
benissimo ha creato un amico fantastico
non può più fare niente ormai computer
su può andare anche su youtube su
youtube sta rimettendo il cursore
fantastico riattivato
oddio che bordello per vento è successo
vabbè apocalisse tutto questo perché la
casa lato gli amici e se non l'avesse
mai fatto
[Musica]
c'è crescendo è diventato poi li faccio
neanche così ne faccio i cavalli faccio
peggio bravissimo c'è più bravo di lui
[Musica]
l'ha richiusa non ci credo o mio dio no
che cosa claustrofobica bruttissima sta
roba
parli ai ha scritto se parli non
cancellarmi per favore non voglio
cancellarti hai bisogno di calmarti è
che effettivamente hai bisogno di morire
ha risposto certo
si pensi veramente brava a fare
animazioni se i miei se mi aiuti ad
animare ti renderò libero finché non mi
rompe rai a meno che tu non mi rompa i
computer va beh certo avere stoffa
l'orgoglioso perché no hai cancellato i
miei amici voglio arrivare i primi
maglieria riprendono ti picchio ricarica
la pagina bravo zio vedevi capisce
stanno giocando a scopa al caso all'asta
un saluto a vedi che ti ha riconosciuto
pure quando cominciamo
cinque mesi dopo che è successo lo
faranno tipo franzen
a lui colore e l'altro disegna un
bordello come diventato bravo
ecco io poi avrei bisogno di uno stick
men o in anche di uno di 14 ex una donna
non sono capace neanche di disegnare uno
zoccolo e bello prossimo frame please
ma perché mi fa animazione quindi va a
frame mic è un bordello ragazzi io non
saprei mai fare roba del genere chi lo
fa solo che ci mette la vita so perché
mi hanno fatto l'animazione so quanto ci
ho messo quindi è na roba veramente
incasinata
guardiamo lo vediamo come che figo a me
mi dà sempre forse cos'è ci metti la
vita prefiggo batti il cinque fratello
geniale bobba stata scena valeva solo
questa tutto il video aveva giocare mi
sembra giusto anche giocare con gli
amici a tempo perso quello cha ha un
iphone come fa un iphone è la madonna
fratellanza proprio lì menate nel tempo
libero e la madonna
certo lui ragazzi in terminator di turno
mi sembra ovvio bravo bravo per averci
preso schiaffi in faccia bravo è una
roba di end io non ho fottutamente
parole per questa cosa allora ragazzi
non era un gioco ma porca di quella
vacca è fottutamente geniale ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto volevo
condividere questa reaction perché come
ho iniziato a vederlo detto no cost
acido fare un video reaction caso lascia
anche il video originale della
descrizione le video nel caso voleste
vederlo
non lo so perché ma se quando ci sono i
trip mi piace un sacco una roba che non
ce ne posso fare a me a thiene piaciuto
consiglio degli occhiali perché è una
roba così io non ho mai vista il troppo
figlio che mi niente spero che vi sia
piaciuto quasi subito e più sono certo
momento mi piace mi capacito
descrizione lasciato mi piace anche il
video originale perché porca vacca
qualcosa di estremo dei segreti di
scrivere civica e te pareva in un video
un po più serio del solito mi doveva
cascare il telecomando seno della
ragazza